U.N Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
on a tour of the Khmer rouge's notorious
prison told slang
under its brutal regime an estimated 20
000 people were imprisoned here
only 12 survived
memory of these genocides
yeah it must be preserved to avoid
similar situations to happen in the
future wherever it was
on the other side of Phnom Penh however
little agreement at the conclusion of
the East Asian Summit the United States
here to strengthen ties in the
indo-pacific region had pushed for
condemnation of the war in Ukraine
for others that wasn't an option
no Collective decisions were made today
because the United States and Western
colleagues insisted on absolutely
unacceptable language regarding the
situation in and around Ukraine
as the meeting concluded the honorary
gavel and the chairmanship of asean was
handed over
the new chairman the president of
Indonesia has conceded it'll be a
challenging year ahead in the light of
increasing global conflict
[Applause]
[Music]
asean should not let Karen geopolitical
Dynamic turn into a new good war in our
region
all eyes will now turn to Bali where the
presidents of China and the U.S are due
to meet on Monday the White House has
played down expectations although Joe
Biden says he hopes for a Frank an
honest discussion with his counterpart I
know Xi Jinping I spent more time than
any other world leader I know him well
he knows me there's no we have very
little misunderstanding we just got to
figure out where the red lines are and
what we're what are the most important
things to each of us
final handshakes and farewells but still
a while before many of these leaders
head for home
storm clouds rolling in over Phnom Penh
at the end of The asean Summit with the
Diplomatic volleys fired here over the
weekend at just the first in a week of
international diplomacy that'll now move
on to Bali and Bangkok and hopefully
some resolution Yet to Come Tony Chang
Al Jazeera Phnom Penh